people keep calling me a wonderkind i
don't even know what that means
i i mean i know what it means it means
very successful for your age
so i guess it makes sense but
it's a weird word
hey ryan hello one second
hey pam it's great to see you it's
michael in hey yeah there he is there he
is he's back and he's with a beard
he has facial hair look at him all grown
up and no place to go hello mr sunny
crockett
i'm tubbs
okay should we get started oh yeah let's
get started because uh yes because it
was a very serious business yeah and uh
exactly this is a business meeting
not that that's right that's right fire
guys are starting any fires fire guys
you weren't here for that you're for
what when he started how big he is look
at you you are so
mature and old and
little man now you're like our little
little old man boy michael
everybody bearded man boy wow let me say
something i know i used to be a temp
here but now everything is different i'd
like your respect
i am your boss now you're gonna have to
treat me the same way you treated jan
i got away with everything under the
last boss and it wasn't good for me at
all so i want guidance i want leadership
but don't just like boss me around you
know
like lead me lead me
when i'm in the mood
to be led
i hooked up with her on february 13th
if i had to i could clean out my desk in
five seconds
and nobody would ever know i had ever
been here
and i'd forget to
hey um
what's the deal with this guy he's
really into kelly huh
yeah they're really great together it
makes me wonder if i made a mistake no
no no come on i think you guys are both
happier now right
you're single plenty of girls to date
right
yeah
maybe we weren't right together but
it's weird i'd rather she be alone
than with somebody
is that love
that's about it yeah
excuse me sir on the dunder mifflin a
team
excuse me sir i'm sure you're just
checking your grinder account
but
you can't check smart phones during
trivia it's against the rules okay i'm
turning it off
okay you're not turning it off i won't i
won't look at it sir
i can't i can't not
touch it okay then we're gonna have to
take it away
thank you
thank you
okay i can't i cannot have my phone i'm
sorry
i want to be with my phone
i am in love with kali kapoor
and i don't know how i'm going to feel
tomorrow or the next day or the day
after that but i do know that right here
right now all i can think about is
spending the rest of my life with her
again that could change
kelly oh hello ed
you look well
i wanted to say i'm sorry
for treating about the past couple years
i was in my mid-20s and
i was going through a lot of stuff
how's my favorite branch doing
all right
ronnie was black things were an all-time
sad here but then i got an email from
ryan that he was coming back to town and
i called the temp agency and i told them
i will pay you any amount just give me
ryan howard give him to me i want him i
need him
and you gotta go tea i did did you get
that after you helped me move and you
saw mine yes
go tea fire
the guy
hey kevin
that's really funny yeah it's great to
see you kev you too i'm keeping a list
of everyone who wrongs me so when i'm
back on top they'll be sorry
kevin just made the list
jim
i want to apologize for how i treated
you last year
i
lost sight of myself and
now that i've quit the rat race i
realize there's so much more to life
than being the youngest vp in the
company's history
i've even started um volunteering
giving back to the community that's
great
you're talking about your court order
community service
i don't need a judge to tell me to keep
my community clean but he did right
all right all right
hey ryan could you start consolidating
all our rolodex information into outlook
uh it doesn't seem like there's much of
a point if the company's going under but
if the company doesn't go under then
we'll finally have all our contacts in
one program the company's probably going
under to go either way it seems like
it's leaning one way maybe we should
just wait and find out definitely okay
so should we wait to find out before we
start doing all this stuff nah might as
well do it now
hey ryan how's it going
here's the thing um
i've tried it like five different ways
in my head
and oh got one um
i'm such a perfectionist
that i'd kind of rather not do it at all
than do a crappy version simple data
entry though so there's really only one
way to do it sounds like you have a
really specific vision for it do you
want to maybe just take a walk at it you
know what what i think i know the
problem great i think you seem
distracted yep these are amazing you
took all these i've always found beauty
in uncommon places
homeless people graffiti photography
lets me capture all that
have you ever been photographed before
oh just by like friends well here's what
i've been doing around
here ryan
has never made a sale
and he started a fire
trying to make a cheesy pita
and everybody thinks he's a tease well
you know what
he doesn't know anything
and neither do you
so suck on that
question dwight why am i being forced to
come in tomorrow and pretend that a
website made sales that i made this is a
temporary measure to increase the
legitimacy of the site i don't like when
my clients call me to help them use the
website i'm not seeing commissions on
that i hear you stanley that is a great
observation problems like that will not
happen when we launch dunder mifflin
infinity 2.0 when will that be tbd
phyllis did the police solve the problem
with yes yes they did yes they did yes
the social networking feature of the
dunder mifflin infiniti website was
infiltrated by sexual predators
i don't understand why our website needs
to have social networking at all yeah i
actually have to agree with dwight on
that one it's all about creating a
one-stop consumer experience all right
you're chatting with your friends you're
talking about the latest music about the
election all of it is happening in our
virtual paper store and then an older
gentleman asks you boxers or briefs i
don't get the big fuss here i like the
site if i had created a website with
this many problems i'd kill myself do
you have a question kelly yeah i have a
lot of questions number one how dare you
i never went to thailand
really
i went to fort lauderdale
was it nice
yeah it was amazing
there's a great pad thai place though
i love bad times
you've never had pad thai no
there's a lot i haven't done
fyi tonight we will be hosting at louis
vulpes wow i love their breadsticks oh
their breadsticks are like crack 11
people say like crack who've obviously
never done crack well the breadsticks
are like what then ryan what can i use i
don't know something from your world the
breadsticks are like scrapbooking you're
right you're right no i'm a middle-class
fraud
hey i'm woof i'm facebook what's up
facebook i sent you a facebook message
yesterday i still haven't heard anything
back you should have sent me a woof a
watch when you send a woof it goes your
home phone cell phone email facebook
twitter and home screen all the same
time
[Music]
whoops.com
wolf t-shirts who wants one just imagine
that you're at spring break daytona
beach here we go okay everyone's like
hey dude what's up with all the hotties
in the wolf shirts or uh hey what's up
with that helicopter it's rye from woof
it's ry the wolf guy ride from wolf he's
up there what's he dropping wow what's
falling on us man woof condoms 50 000
condoms out of the sky look at that he
threw him on the ground look that's just
a marketing campaign you got nine days
let's say you do get the money what are
you gonna do with it the first lesson of
silicon valley actually is that you only
think about the user the experience you
actually don't think about the money
ever
that sounds weird no it's not weird andy
and you know what else we have an offer
from washington university so monetize
that
you